so let's remember what this thing is
about surround pictures and online
service that creates virtual tours on
behalf of real estate agents and their
clients as future there's always type
anyway a screenshot did you despite it
you in silent you're too busy stressing
about what's the HSE keyword I don't
know it quick let's try and come up with
as many years I've is a screenshot 0
final virtual tour web page is shown
below he go this is a real service by
the way you can go look up these guys
you can find this stuff and you can pan
around become a look okay now it starts
to talk a little bit about this which
we're going to refer back to you but the
question at least the first one is
explain how I volunteers in processing
and communications technology for end
users have enabled such a service to
gain mainstream stat okay very quickly
two things number one this question was
pretty well done okay and I think that's
partly because they were not that remark
saw that which means you could get away
with not having a huge amount of detail
on there but also because you got us a
very very similar question to this
before and I was testing to see okay how
should you pay attention and learn your
lesson from the other one which was done
quite disastrously i think was about
Siri in Google now and the phrasing is
very similar because in the age of seen
you get questions like this okay you're
like oh yeah I remember that question
anyway so we did do pretty okay on it
but let me just rehearse it for you
because that's what this time is for we
want to revise as much as possible so
when you the actuator see you'll nail it
okay so two marks because it's two parts
to it right explain how advances in
number one processing and number two
communications technology have allowed
this Otis to gain popularity well let's
have a look at what the what the service
is right so you remember the basic way
that it works they take a whole bunch of
pictures and then they stitch them
together in a special proprietary
software way which I'll as you then move
around as if it was just one picture in
a 3d space okay so let's think about
number one leave this for a second the
processing me it's required
for this okay so press se as immediately
you ought to think okay the CPU that's
the main thing that does processing
right well what kinds of advances that
was the question wasn't it what kinds of
advances in CPUs make this service
possible why might this service not have
been possible say five to ten years ago
or at least not as good ok so the common
answers and this is basically what else
to be format is that there's a lot of
graphics intensive and if you're looking
for sort of like that the right language
to use ok this is this is the way I
would say this is the terminology
ologies there's a lot of graphics
intensive tasks involved in turning a
bunch of still images which are flat ok
just a matrix of pixels ok into
something which is spherical in which
you can pan around and have it be a kind
of seamless experience right so via this
is a graphics intensive task number one
it's the Cheney images together and then
number two your computer at home I'm
having to interpret that stitch together
version of the picture and users
computers
you really actually need quite a lot of
power underneath your computer to be
able to do this kind of thing we kind of
take it for granted because our phones
can all do this now that ipod touches
and it's very very simple it's very
small and compact but these are this is
this an appointment these are advances
in processing technology that are fairly
recent okay all right again advances in
communications technology so and you
could have done this in this way you
could have had like a little subheadings
okay you can help me out with this one
it's a pretty obvious one right what
advances in communications technology
were needed to make this technology
possible
what do you reckon Vicki okay let's take
that answer and let's think about how
many marks would you give it if you saw
that word as a sentence for the second
sort of like part of this is how much
did you give it I'd give it a big fat
zero out of one now it's a good place to
start though so can we build on it a
little bit what what about the internet
what's been the advance because the
internet is old it's very old right but
so what's been the events it's allowed
this to enable this okay good right so
faster speeds so let's see faster speeds
for accessing the internet okay it's
number one any other sort of thoughts
yeah good so so not just do we get
faster internet but we get internet in
more places okay so you can say this is
our first little some point you can say
widespread access
okay so you can access these kinds of
things from your phone and that's really
easy and cheap as well ok now it's also
worth mentioning these two fit together
even though you might not have mentioned
it in a question that was only worth two
marks if there are a few more marks what
else might you say can you see it as an
important relationship between the
communication system and the process
assistant how they advance together okay
because the more processing power you've
got the more compressed you can make
files right which means they're smaller
and that means you can send more of them
through your communications network okay
so if you have more marks to play with
here and you need to provide more detail
on your answer that might be a direction
that you go when you want to draw out
the relationship between the two because
there's quite a quite a close
relationship between them